here let me ask you this question
because there's a
question that was posed here what are
your thoughts on dating a girl with only
fans personally i think it's simping
what do you think
so a very key thing about dating girls
is the context in which you meet a girl
is one of the most critical elements so
if you meet a girl
while she's if you meet a stripper at
the strip club the context in which
you're meeting her
is that you are a customer and she's
always going to view through that
customer lens
and very very difficult to transcend
that and go
beyond that because that initial context
is going to be over there if you meet a
girl
at a coffee shop and she happens to be a
stripper
completely different ball game because
the context in which you've met her
has been oh this is i'm out in the world
i'm not in work mode
it's not a customer this is someone that
i can interact with and
and treat like uh treat normally so if
you have a girl that has
only fans then i would say one
what level only fans is she on like is
she
you know a very explicit type of only
fans girl she's just the type that
alright cool i'll sell like cute
pictures of myself
a little exploration on that but also
too like how did you meet this girl did
you meet her before
did you meet her on a dating app um it's
it takes
it requires a lot more kind of case by
case i would say because uh one of the
girls i was
going out with um during the pandemic
times was a porn star
right and so a lot of guys would be like
oh like how could you ever it's like she
was
super cool very fun but also the context
in which i met her was
outside of the you know if i'd met her
at a porn commission or something
or if i met her through an escort
service then totally view me through
that lens
so you know it really just depends on
the the context in which you've met this
girl you kind of have to evaluate it
based on that case-by-case basis
do not be her customer do not be her
simping only fans customer do not be her
simping you know
stripper customer um be the pimp
do it uh you know do what the tape
brothers do and run their only fans and
make some money off it that's
that's my recommendation and no lie it's
definitely kind of fun as a little bit
of ecoboost like when i was going out
with that um
porn star or with like i've i've gone on
a couple girls i found out later had
only fans
but um well so it kind of is a little
bit of a like you know
ego booster your guy card where it's
like oh you're going out
you have locked in the girl that all
these other dudes
fantasize about um so there is something
a little bit kind of fun to that so
you